and i will be sending a letter to the
department of justice
asking for a criminal referral because
he has lied to congress
we have scientists that will line up by
the dozens to say that the research he
was funding was gain of function
he's doing this because he has a
self-interest to cover his tracks
and to cover his connection to wuhan lab
that's kentucky senator rand paul
threatening to send the justice
department a criminal referral against
dr anthony fauci
during a heated exchange between the two
on capitol hill yesterday
the republican senator pressing fauchi
about the origins of kovitt and funding
of the wuhan laboratory in china
but the white house chief of medical
advisor chief medical advisor
is standing firm denying any wrongdoing
you just have to see it watch for
fouching knowing that it is a crime to
lie to congress
do you wish to retract your statement of
may 11 where you claimed that the nih
never funded gain of function research
in wujon i have never lied
before the congress and i do not retract
that statement you shake an animal virus
and you increase this transability to
humans
right you're saying that's not gain a
function yeah that is correct and
and senator paul you do not know what
you are talking about
they took animal viruses that only occur
in animals
and they increase their transmissibility
to humans how you can say that is not
gain a function it is not it's a dance
and you're dancing around this
because you're trying to obscure
responsibility for four million people
dying around the world
you are implying that what we did
was responsible for the deaths of
individual
i totally resent that and if anybody is
lying
here senator it is you trey gowdy
well harris i have said oftentimes
before one of the greatest casualties of
this pandemic has been medicine
and science i mean we live in a world
where we are desperate for something
to rise above the political den
something we can trust and believe in
and it used to be medicine look i i
don't know dr fauci i know rand a little
bit
they're they're both medical doctors i
know what makes for great tv to have
this conversation
in five-minute increments on television
why don't you meet with one another but
why don't you just go
no cameras you both are md's go
sit down i don't have a friend that
understands gain of function
i i don't know a single person that
knows the difference between
rna and dna vaccine maybe maybe you and
i have different friends
maybe my friends are just not that smart
but we don't talk about that
what we talk about is how do we survive
this this looming coming
season of disquiet that is coming back
and it'd be great if we could rely on
medicine so
look rand dr fauci go talk about this in
private first
that's what the bible says to do that'd
be a pretty good idea for both of you
all
yes it does morgan well i think it's
important to have this
uh discus discussion and and josh rogan
from the washington post also cnn
contributor
uh tweeted out last night and he was
right he said that uh that the nih was
fun funding gain and function research
at this lab
but what the nih reportedly did
according to this washington post
columnist
is they didn't classify it as gain of
function research
because by not classifying it then they
then they got away from having
uh the oversight mechanism that the nih
requires
if you are funding it so why does that
matter number one it matters because if
they are funding gain of function
research
in these labs or anywhere around the
world where i think it's proven they
were
and they're not declaring it in order to
get around an oversight mechanism
uh it's important that they number one
that they stop doing it
it's also secondly important to know um
why do we have this oversight in place
could we if we had proper oversight of
the gain of function
uh research going on in this lab would
we have been able to better understand
the origins of covid which no one knows
and we do not know if it came from this
lab that signs are pointing to there
and finally i would just say to back up
trey you know
there there is one entity that's
responsible for all of this and it's not
fouchy
it's the chinese communist party and we
need to continue to make sure no matter
what we're arguing about the united
states that our efforts are focused
on getting the chinese communist party
to be accountable for the origins of
coven
there you go all right we do want to get
to this and trey you had brought up the
coveted vaccine
republican congressman steve scalise is
talking about why he in fact
finally chose because he he was waiting
he said he was delaying
he finally chose to get the covet
vaccination now watch
months ago i had tested for the
antibodies
you know and so i would imagine maybe a
year ago early off i might have gotten
coveted but
uh didn't really have any symptoms but
had the antibodies but ultimately with
this new delta variant you're seeing
i've toured a lot of hospitals in the
last
few weeks and you're seeing the cases go
up it's not
to the alarming level that we saw last
year by any stretch you do see
about 95 to 98 of people in the hospital
for covet or people that aren't
vaccinated
and and i just you know i wanted i was
ready to get the vaccine i've always
felt it was
safe and effective i applaud what
president trump did with operation warp
speed to bring
multiple vaccines to the market in the
quickest time ever
but it's not because they cut corners
they tested it on thousands of people
before ultimately you got that fda
conditional use approval so
it's safe and effective i took it and i
wanted to show the picture to
to just encourage people you know while
we discussed this and kayleigh
i want to get your top line thoughts on
this because you were just saying much
of what he's saying yesterday
i mean you but look at this is uh
congressman
scalise on sunday getting his first
coveted shot he says he's getting a
two-shot series so he'll be back in 21
or 28 days depending on which one he got
pfizer or moderna respectively that's
right and
like congressman steve scalise i had
covid19
even though i was asymptomatic i went
and got the vaccine for a few reasons
well first let me say as i mentioned
yesterday i saw president trump oversee
this process
he appointed dr stephen hahn at the fda
who approved this vaccine he appointed
robert redfield at the cdc i got the
vaccine because one
could keep you from getting a variant
number two even if you get a very you're
95 percent less likely to be
hospitalized or elderly says it's higher
than that from what he's seeing in
hospitals higher higher than that and
even
more important than any of that is it
reduces your risk of transmitting the
virus so if you have a grandmother a
grandfather or a parent
do it for them if not for yourself even
if you're a young person
so when you talk to people and and i do
i i want to know where people are i want
to meet them right where we are
right dr siegel and i talk about this
all the time because
i'm not a doctor as trey said you know
we're not all epidemiologists
you know breaking down our mrna and dna
but at the
at the baseline point we want to
understand what's right for us
right i am so confused about the
messaging coming out of this white house
why can't they simply say that what
those people on that plane going from
texas to dc did was
wrong they were flouting the federal
regulations for being in the air
no matter what their vaccination status
the rest of us wear a mask
whether we love that process or not
that's how it is
why can't the white house simply say you
know what our next
proving ground is not going to be at
your front door it's going to be at the
front door of the fda
we're going to go get them and and tell
them to give full approval
scientifically can they get there from
this emergency use authorization
i would say 80 percent of the people
i've talked to who have waited like
scalise did for a period of time
that's their issue they're like why
don't they mainstream it like every
other drug
i mean if you read the back of the
bottle of an anti-inflammatory there are
a lot of indicators
for why you might want to choose a
different drug why can't the fda look at
this why isn't the white house
pressuring that point
that's such a great point absolutely and
that's a lot of people who have
hesitation they've pointed out
why isn't the fda why haven't they
approved it yet if this administration
is on board
it only serves to ignite more questions
in the american people
especially when that mixed messaging
from this administration trickles down
for example to the state and local level
like in l.a county
where in complete contrast to the
message of vaccine efficacy they're
still demanding people wear masks
indoors and outdoors etc especially to
combat what they call
the pandemic of un vaccination i think
that's why steve scalise for example is
such a wonderful ambassador to this
at least he is sending a clear message
about the vaccine
efficacy remember as well we talked
about you know the flood of migrants on
the border
just 38 people in the entire country of
haiti have been vaccinated so the fact
that in this country
they are prevalent available and free i
hope that more people take advantage of
that
with hopefully a clear messaging going
forward hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now